[Music]
it's time for et's social study here's
what the stars are posting online
Chelsea Clinton took to Facebook to
defend president Trump's son barren but
she also made clear she wasn't endorsing
any of Trump's policies that quote hurt
kids we've got some positivity here for
sure
Lea Michele shared this touching
throwback selfie with her late boyfriend
Glee co-star Cory Monteith while cocoa
Austin and her baby girl Chanel rocked
matching swimwear in Miami Michael B
Jordan shows off his insanely ripped
body in this new shirtless pic and Shahs
of Sunset star AUSA Sultan ramadi and
boyfriend Jermaine Jackson the second
welcomed a baby boy the couple shared
the happy news on Instagram its abs
that's important meanwhile keshia knight
pulliam also gave birth the 37 year old
actress announced the arrival of her
baby girl Ella grace with this adorable
pic of her daughter's feet all snuggled
up I'm so excited about just celebrating
her and finally Tracee Ellis Ross posted
this sweet video hanging out with her
brother Evan and niece Jagger snow
[Music]